[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
thriller film called the island
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie two people
are in the middle of the boat on the
ocean
as the male protagonist clasps his hand
with a female he is drowned by three
other creepy looking persons into the
ocean
suddenly lincoln's six echo snaps awake
and realizes that it was just a dream
a slick led display above the bed greets
lincoln with a good morning message
subsequently another display on his wall
request says presence at the tranquility
center for a wellness evaluation
as lincoln pease the toilet recognizes
that his urine has excessive sodium and
recommends nutrition control
he has a bracelet wrapped in his wrist
which automatically opens a drawer
filled with his clothes
when lincoln steps out of his room we
see plenty of others in there who wear
the same clothes as him
lincoln and others wearing white stroll
together and enter the lift
as the lift continues down holograms
play along the wall showing snapshots of
a beautiful tranquil island among
sparkling blue ocean
the residents are told that the outside
world has become too contaminated to
support life
with the exception of a pathogen-free
island each week
one resident gets to leave the compound
and live on the island by way of a
lottery
just then this week's lottery winner is
announced the winner is
starkweather2delta
an image of starkweather2delta appears
speaking joyfully about how it was
always his dream to go to the island
as the lift reaches its destination
lincoln continues to walk along the
compounds
in the background various people engage
in various chores like yoga activities
fitness exercise and swimming all seem
content
but black tracksuited supervisors are
shown keeping close watch all throughout
the citizens of the compound all of whom
wear white tracksuits
are treated well but their lives are
strictly regimented and regulated
at the cafeteria lincoln swipes his
bracelet and asks for bacon
however the nutritionist advises him
against it for health purposes
seeing this lincoln's best friend jordan
2 delta tells him to watch and learn
she pleases the nutritionist and cheats
her way with bacon
they talk for a while but the guards
alert them of engaging in far too much
proximity
she slides the bacon into lincoln's
plate as they separate
lincoln arrives at the office of dr
merrick the presiding doctor for the
compound
he inquires him about his friendship
with jordan and explains that there are
proximity rules against regular close-up
contact
he is further questioned about the
nightmare he explains to the doctor his
nightmare
when he is probed he confesses that he
has begun to question the regimentation
of life at the compound
why is tuesday night tofu night he wants
some bacon for his breakfast
and he wants to wear different colors
other than white for his clothes and
there should be more to life at the
compound than just waiting to go the
island dr merrick calmly tries to
explain that he is lucky to have
survived the contaminated earth
and how the island is the only clean
place left he further explains that he
himself
and all other staff and supervisors at
the compound are ineligible to win the
lottery and cannot ever go to the island
as they are needed to keep the compound
facility operating smoothly
then dr merrick wants to run some tests
on linkedin and has him tied on a
reclining seat
he places some devices on lincoln's
cheek that crawl into his eye
he assures lincoln that these micro
sensors will upload data for 24 hours
and then pass out through his urine
lincoln then arrives at the work center
for work
he and a citizen named jones three echo
are using infuser tools to feed
nutrients into tubes that lead to where
the citizens meals are prepared
lincoln is bored with a job although
jones finds it satisfying
the calm of the work center is suddenly
broken as a female citizen
lima 1 alpha collapses lima 1 alpha is
heavily pregnant and it appears she's
gone into labor
the other women near her are ecstatic
for her as she is now destined to go to
the island with her baby
lincoln then illicitly visits a power
plant basement where his friend
technician james mccord works there he
discovers a live moth in the ventilation
shaft
he captures the bug and hides it inside
a matchbox
in the evening lincoln tells jordan
about the flying bug he found
leading him to realize that the outside
world might not be contaminated
he has a feeling that something is wrong
jordan however is baffled at how
lincoln's six echo is convinced of bad
things being hidden
behind the seemingly good life at the
compound
soon after the walls in the social
center light up with holographic
displays as the lottery begins citizens
all around the compound stop and begin
watching nearby monitors and screens
the community announcer begins the usual
speech about the lottery and a lucky
winner heading to the island
the spin soon begins as it stops
jordan's name is shown in the hologram
cheer and applause erupt she is frozen
lincoln seems unhappy at the thought of
losing his best friend and at the chance
of going to the island slipping away one
more time
to congratulate her he touches her arm
and says goodbye
the supervisor halts their brief union
as it breached the proximity rule
that night lincoln sees the same
nightmare again he awakes suddenly
leaning up to look at the flying insect
and his face lights up with an idea
he sneaks along the compound into sector
six and releases the insect
it flies and he follows he ends up in a
hallway in a medical sector
he ducks through a door finding a
utility closet with a number of blue
medical lab coats
one of which he puts on as he navigates
his way through the medical center
he looks through the window of a medical
room and sees lima 1 alpha delivering
the baby
suddenly the doctor injects something
into her body and she starts trembling
and then dies
meanwhile the nurse carries the baby
into another room and presents the newly
born girl to a couple
the woman looks exactly like lima 1
alpha
lincoln is shocked and goes into the
nurse station he finds stark weather 2
delta lying on an operating table in the
surgery room
as they are about to make an incision
through his chest starkweather2delta
wakes up and starts to run
he is chased by several guards and is
finally hounded by a gun
lincoln hides in a corner watching this
dr merritt comes into the security room
to ask about the incident
upon close surveillance the doctor
realizes that the disguise lincoln had
seen everything
he rings the alarm bells and wants
lincoln captured
meanwhile lincoln heads towards the
compound where girls reside to try and
rescue jordan
lincoln finds jordan and tries to make
her understand that there is no island
and that she will soon be killed for
organs
she is beyond surprised he convinces her
and they both run to escape from the
establishment
several guards chase them but they
escape through a series of underground
corridors
and finally emerge into the outside
world outside
they continue to run while staring and
wander at the world around them
although the terrain is rocky and looks
barren they are very able to breathe the
air
there's no trace of any contamination as
they see a living snake
they now believe that the earth is not
contaminated and the island is just a
lie
back in the compound the community
announcer delivers fabricated news that
lincoln has been quarantined due to the
exposure to the contamination
while jordan has been safely transported
to the island
elsewhere the truth about this compound
is revealed as dr merrick makes a sales
presentation to potential clients
it is revealed that this facility is in
fact a bioengineering facility where ag
agnates are grown
agnate is a clone of a regular person
grown directly into adulthood
matching the biological age of the
client its dna completely identical to
the clients
an agnate is meant as a source of
replacement body parts for an ailing
client female agnates can also serve as
surrogate wombs for a female client who
cannot carry a baby herself
however dr merrick falsely claims that
the ag nates are kept in a vegetative
state
never achieving consciousness never
think or feel anything
they are products and not humans after
the presentation
dr merrick hires burkina mercenary
albert laurent
to find and return lincoln and jordan of
the compound dr
merrick explains that the world doesn't
know that the agnate products are alive
if knowledge of this becomes public the
institute will be shut down for ethical
violations
dr merrick explains that locating jordan
2 delta is particularly paramount
her sponsor the person she's cloned from
is sarah jordan
she is comatose following a car accident
without multiple organ transplants
she'll die within three days this
explains the lottery
and agnate wins when their sponsor
requires body part harvest
elsewhere lincoln and jordan reach a bar
where they manage to find mccord
and he takes the two of them to his home
there he explains to them about their
existence
how they are human clones meant to serve
as sources of body parts for the people
they're cloned from
the memories they have of their
respective childhoods families and lives
before the contamination are basic
memory imprints
mccord also explains their names lincoln
and jordan are the surnames of their
sponsors
echo means that lincoln has been alive
for three years while delta means jordan
is for
the two in jordan's name is a regional
code for new york
where sarah jordan lives six is a
regional code for los angeles
where lincoln's sponsor tom lincoln
lives lincoln and jordan decide that
they must locate their sponsors and
spread the truth of their existence and
the institute
mccord assist them with maps credit
cards cash
and one crucial piece of advice to not
trust any human
meanwhile baran and his team locate
lincoln and jordan through the micro
sensors inside lincoln's body
the men arrive there and kill mccord but
the other two somehow manage to board
the train to los angeles
they expect to meet lincoln's sponsor
there after a lot of struggles
they finally arrives at tom lincoln's
estate lincoln peeks into a security
camera near the door
it reads his retinal prints which are a
match for his sponsors
the door unlocks and opens for them the
two of them go inside and find photos of
tom lincoln
at that moment tom lincoln comes up from
behind mistaking them for intruders and
swings a golf club
soon he freezes in shock and amazement
when he sees lincoln's face
they converse for some time and tom
reveals that he is suffering from liver
damage and that lincoln is his insurance
policy
the two agnates revealed to him the
reality of the institute and beg for his
help
tom assures them to take them to a
television news channel to flash the
truth
tom asks the two of them to stay there
while he goes up to get a pair of shoes
in his room tom lincoln secretly calls
the merrick institute and asks them what
his insurance policy is doing at his
home
he comes downstairs and as they are
about to move jordan sees tom's eyes and
alerts lincoln that he is lying
tom plans to trick lincoln to go with
him to bring him to an ambush
they'd travel in tom's car when suddenly
lauren and his team approach them and
start shooting at the vehicle
lincoln drives as fast as he can while
engaging in a fight with tom
as the both of them flung out of the
vehicle lauren is holding his gun
aiming to shoot the clone lincoln copies
tom's scottish accent making the two
indistinguishable
lauren is baffled he doesn't know who
the real lincoln is
lincoln performs a sleight of hand and
adjusts his bracelet in tom's wrist
lauren then realizes that the clone
would be wearing a bracelet and upon
seeing one
he shoots at tom tom is dead and his
body is sent to the institute
lincoln returns to tom's estate and
jordan and he make love to each other
back at the institute dr muric and the
incubation chief find out that the four
newest generations of agnates have shown
interesting neural patterns
they inherit memory imprints from their
sponsors because of this
many agnates have shown the ability to
question which can be harmful to the
establishment
dr merrick believes the only solution is
a recall the termination of half the ag
nates
and the disposal of almost 200 million
dollars worth of products
the mechanism for the recall is already
in place a large numbers of ag nates
will all be chosen simultaneously as
lottery winners to go to the island for
termination
one such lottery is shown and jones
three echo is one of the ones chosen
technicians and medical personnel are
seen going to the incubation room and
prematurely extracting incubating ag
mates from the incubation pods
meanwhile lincoln and jordan plan to
save the living agnates
lincoln believes that the holographic
control room is the main base of the
establishment
if he destroys it all the ag mates can
see the reality that the holograms have
been hiding from them
he dresses like tom lincoln and heads
towards merrick institute in a chopper
on the other hand jordan allows herself
to be caught by lauren and taken to the
institute as well
in the car lauren looks thoughtfully at
the thermal implant under the skin of
jordan's wrist as she anxiously runs her
fingers across it
as they arrive lauren meets dr merrick
in his office
who expresses his gratitude for lauren's
services
however he learns that sarah jordan may
not survive even with the organ
transplants
he now has moral qualms about the
clone's treatment after witnessing their
fight for survival
elsewhere lincoln injures the institute
rep and heads towards the holographic
room
while jordan is in bed waiting for her
organs to be taken out for her sponsor
and suddenly
she opens fire at one of the guards she
goes out and meets lincoln and gives him
a key she has stolen
meanwhile the doctors investigate tom's
dead body and realize that it is the
client's dead body
they inform dr merrick who hurriedly
issues a warning to find lincoln
some agnates are guaranteed a trip to
the island but in reality are being
taken to be terminated
jordan sees that the agnates are being
escorted to a section of the building
and follows them lincoln finds the
reactor and tries to shut down the
hologram power grid
but is shot by dr merrick the two fight
meanwhile as the ag nates are being
loaded into a lift
jones is suspicious and tries to resist
but they are locked in what turns out to
be an incineration chamber
the security activates it and just then
jordan arrives
lauren soon follows and threatens the
security to deactivate it
the guard has no choice but to comply
the ag nates gasp for breath
while the reactor fan overloads and is
surging out of control
lincoln is being strangled to death by
dr merrick but he manages to get hold of
the gun and shoots at the doctor's neck
the reactor fan spirals out of control
and destroys everything it meets
dr merrick is dead the holographic
illusion is now shattered
all the ag nates can see that there is
no contamination in the outside world
in surprise all the agnates walk out of
the establishment and wander through the
world they had never seen
lincoln and jordan kiss each other as
lauren smiles at them
the movie ends with lincoln and jordan
sailing away in a boat together toward
an island
fulfilling their dream of one day going
to such a place
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching